be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about gladiator and world
breaker Hulk now what I'm hoping is that
at the end of all this you'll have a
stronger understanding of the character
as well as why so many fans are excited
about the introduction of gladiator Hulk
in the movie Thor Ragnarok and so while
fans of comics will be aware that
gladiator and world breaker Hulk are
completely different characters the to
actually go hand in hand by way of the
progression of banner during the
mid-2000s coming out of editor-in-chief
Joe Quesada as multi-year plan to return
Marvel to its classical roots the
efforts of casada were also focus on
keeping Marvel out of the reverie
following the near busts of the comic
industry in the 1990s and the company's
subsequent recovery to this end and
under the writing of Mark Millar Marvel
launched civil war in 2006 as a line
wide event centering on the moral and
legal debate of freedom versus security
which impacted everyone from Tony Stark
and Captain America as its antagonist to
lower to your characters like heroes for
hire and Prowler
however because powerhouses like Hulk
and Thor would have swayed the battle in
the events conclusion measures had to be
taken to remove Hulk and Thor from the
comic landscape and an effort to remove
this issue and provide a more even
playing field when Thor's removal took
place as part of the Avengers
disassembled event and involved Loki
leading an army against Asgard
culminating in Thor traveling to the
afterlife the removal of Hulk came by
way of the Marvel Civil War lead-up
one-shot New Avengers Illuminati as it
was written by Brian Michael Bendis
providing a read con by focusing on the
fallout of the kree-skrull war a
conflict involving the two named alien
races and spanning the universe because
a conflict came close to earth and
nearly ended in the planets destruction
Doctor Strange and name of the
Submariner Charles Xavier Reed Richards
Black Bolt and Tony Stark came together
to form the Illuminati which would act
in secret protecting the earth from all
threats both native and extraterrestrial
an aside track here for those who have
been keeping up with events in comics
over the last few years and 2014 Marvel
launched original sin as part of their
ongoing events functioning as companions
to Jonathan Hickman ston winds out
leading into Secret Wars during the
storyline model revealed that Nick Fury
had been operating in the same capacity
as the Illuminati for much longer time
and had been systematically eliminating
threats from within the earth and
on including other dimensions and other
universes now the reason I brought this
up is that no explanation had ever been
offered as to whether or not the
Illuminati were aware of Nick Fury's
larger role but by virtue of the civil
war tie-in Bendis revealed that the
Illuminati and Nick Fury had come to the
conclusion that the whole persona was
too unstable for banner to control and
too powerful for the Illuminati to
contain into the sand and under the
planning of Reed Richards a vessel was
constructed and the Hulk was tricked
into boarding of satellite under the
guise of destroying it before crashed
into Earth after which he was jettisoned
into space with a ship programmed to
land on a planet containing lush flora
but devoid of sentient life however in
the midst of its journey the vessel
passed through an uncharted wormhole
resulting in Hulk crash landing on Sekar
kicking off the Planet Hulk event as it
was written by Greg Pak gladiator Hulk
made his debut after being taken
prisoner by the armies of the Red King
being forced to fight in sukar's
gladiatorial games
what planet Hulk would focused heavily
on Hulk for ending several other
gladiators and forming a team referred
to as the warbound the story also saw
Hulk doing battle against the Silver
Surfer who had also been captured by the
Red King and stood as the reigning
champion pitting the two against one
another by concluding with Silver Surfer
freeing himself and the rest of the
gladiators instead of escaping hooked
her to leading the warbound and the
various races around Sekar in a
revolution against the Red King
resulting in the King's death and the
Hulk settling down with a woman named
tiara who we had taken as his wife
now with the events of Planet Hulk
coincided with civil war on the whole
the powers of the Hulk did not see much
change during the storylines instead the
main focus of The Hulk was initially
rooted in escape followed by a sense of
duty and honor that came with being the
strongest other gladiators and its power
to free the planet from the control of
the Red King and so with the events of
Planet Hulk included Bruce Banner made
his next appearance and one more hole
returning to the planet Earth alongside
his warbound
the events between Planet Hulk and world
war hulk were explained over the course
of the story stating that Hulk had been
made king of Sekar and produced a child
with higher but when the ship he arrived
in was being investigated by individuals
who look to construct a statue the
vessel was compromised resulting in a
nuclear explosion that wiped out Hulk's
Kingdom killing kieara and his child in
the process blaming the Illuminati for
the death of his family due to the fact
that the ship was powered by a nuke
reactor the world war hulk event saw the
introduction of world breaker hulk by
way of Bruce Banner and its angriest
form and wielding a level of strength
hitherto unseen in any previous
iterations in tearing an absolute swath
through the superhuman community hope
initially encountered a group known as
the gamma Corps a paramilitary team
composed of super soldiers irradiated
with Hulk's gamma based DNA and what the
members of the gamma Corps consisted of
individuals with skills ranging from
martial arts to weapons and tactics the
group was almost immediately overpowered
and imprisoned by Hulk using obedience
disks that disabled their powers
continuing his theme over the course of
the story's first half the Hulk faced
off against the Ghost Rider Johnny Blaze
the New Avengers of Wolverine spider-man
Carol Danvers Ben Grimm and Luke Cage as
well as a full contingent a former
Avengers members defeating and
imprisoning all of them using obedience
disks turning his sights to Charles
Xavier owing to his involvement as part
of the Illuminati during the battle with
the x-men in their efforts to protect
the mansion the team was virtually
unable to do anything to stop the Hulk
with Colossus having his arms broken
wall in his metal form sending out an
SOS to the entirety of the movie's
community and in listen the aid of
juggernaut and abomination and the
group's efforts to subdue the Hulk where
the battle was expected to see
juggernaut tip the odds in the team's
favor instead abomination was easily
defeated and Cain Marko was completely
overpowered and nearly killed with a
hawk leaving after learning of the
fallout of the House of M and the
drastic reduction in the mutant
population following this the one war
hulk event unfolded with banner doing
battle against the Fantastic Four Tony
Stark and his Hulkbuster armor name of
the Submariner and Doctor Strange all of
which was broadcast in some former
fashion on national television and was
witnessed by Robert Reynolds not a
sidetrack for a second when he was
originally introduced into Marvel Comics
the century stood as a retcon by writer
Paul Jenkins and artist J League
establishing that Robert Reynolds was a
being of tremendous power developing his
abilities from an enhanced version of
Steve Rogers Super Soldier Serum and
serving as an influence for the
Fantastic Four
spider-man Doctor Strange and Charles
Xavier regarded those superhero antics
as well as a close friend of Bruce
Banner
for his original appearance came out of
Marvel Knights which produced stories
written and drawn by Joe Quesada
independently owned comic company with
gisado taking over as editor-in-chief in
this century was rolled over into
Marvel's mainstream line of publications
establishing that the Robert Reynolds
and boy dichotomy was a form of
schizophrenia and multiple personality
disorder however whether it was by
virtue of Greg pack riding himself into
a hole or having planned it all along
with Hogan his warbound transforming the
entirety of Madison Square Garden into a
gladiatorial arena with the intention of
having the Illuminati fight one another
to the death
prior to his capture Ironman had visited
mother Reynolds explaining that century
was the only being on earth capable of
going toe-to-toe against the Hulk in his
current form and ending his rampage
where hope seemed to take no interest in
the events as they unfolded after
watching the whole continuous rampage
Reynolds finally stepped up with the
goal of going head-to-head against
banner culminating in a massive battle
between the two that stretched the
entirety of New York City the full
measure of a nurse strength and his
wallbreaker hawk form came when he
stomped on the ground and shook the
entirety of the east coast of the United
States however with a world war hulk
event saw a litany of build-up to the
final confrontation that climax proved
to be anything but in the banneret
century fought each other to a
standstill with each version returning
to their normal human forms allowing
shield to take mana into custody and
imprison him below the Earth's surface
and an effort to keep the Incredible
Hulk persona from running amok on earth
would that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and let me know if
you guys are interested in seeing a full
discussion about what work hold I'm kind
of curious and I'll catch you guys later
peace